bonjour merci des troncs direct sur rt
france alors deux ans après l'assassinât
la fiancée du journaliste jamal arrache
au gie porte plainte aux états unis
contre mohamed bin salman que reproche t
elle concrètement tout simplement il
paraît tout à fait évident que mohammed
bin salman est non seulement le lisant
le bénéficiaire mais le commanditaire
ont probablement tacite ou explicite de
cet assassinat qui était rp tuer le pape
est très comme vous le savez dans les
locaux mêmes du consulat de l'arabie
saoudite à istanbul
pratiquement présence du consul et par
une équipe de tueurs qui étaient venus
avec leur propre passeport depuis
l'arabie saoudite et qui sont repartis
tranquillement après avoir carrément
dépassé ce pauvre homme dans les locaux
du consulat
alors plusieurs membres du cercle
rapproché de mohamed ben salman sont
également visés par cette tante qui sont
ils bah écoutez c'est un il y avait les
services secrets il y à il y a des gens
qui sont identifiés pour avoir été
exécutée cette opération qui sont des
officiers de haut rang
nous avons mentionné nous avons publié
un extrait voici quelques jours du livre
qui paraît ces jours ci aux éditions
jardin de libre ces deux livres de trois
journalistes turcs ferhat m'henni
dramane simsek et les nazis de caravanes
qui s'intitule sauvagerie diplomatique
et qui entrent dans tous les détails de
cette opération est de son contexte et
je pense que ce qui est sidérant pour
nous c'est pour ça que nous en parlons
c'est leur la discrétion des médias
occidentaux et en particulier en france
sur le précédent absolument 108
sanguinaire que constitue cet assassinat
et ce serait la moindre des choses que
des gens qui qu'ils sont repérés qui
sont identifiés en répondre alors on dit
que cette affaire à écorcher l'image et
prince héritier saoudien
mais dans les faits
y at-il eu des partenariats ou des
collaborations entre l'arabie saudite
avec des pays étrangers qui ont été
suspendus il des pays comme le canada ou
l'allemagne ont suspendu des désaccords
malheureusement la france qui est
extrait extrêmement liés et notamment
par ses ventes d'armes à l'arabie
séoudite n'a rien fait et de manière
concomitante les médias français n'ont
pas trop insister sur cette affaire on
n'a pas eu il n'y a pas eu des cris
d'orfraie dans le média français sur cet
événement alors que dans d'autres pays
oui il y en a eu donc ces affaires
mettent en évidence la la dépendance de
nombre de pays et des protagonistes et
de médias vis-à-vis des intérêts
saoudiens et pourquoi selon vous tout
simplement parce que tout le monde
d'aujourd'hui fait la cour à moi ben
mohamed ben salman et aux milliards dont
ils disposent ou dont il est censé
disposer des médias les partenaires de
d'affaires les fournisseurs d'armement
je mentionne évidemment la france comme
fournisseur d'armes qui sont utilisés
dans la guerre absolument inacceptable
de l'ami ces audits contre le yémen qui
est en train de dévaster le yémen il ya
israël il y a des les américains qui
forment les services saoudiens qui sont
qui sent qu'ils sont chez eux en arabie
saoudite
il ya toute une constellation d'intérêt
très lourd qui font que le le poids de
la vie d'un d'un opposant d'un
éditorialiste d'un blogueur à
l'intellectuel comme n'était jamal
khashoggi ne pèse pas très lourd
abstraction faite de toutes les de
toutes les les relations des liens que
cachot qui pouvait avoir dans le monde
deux du renseignement ou dans des eaux
dans des milieux comme les frères
musulmans nés sur le principe assassiné
ainsi un opposant qui ne qui sont posés
par la plume par les mots à au roi est
quelque chose qui inquiète absolument
absolument scandaleux et inimaginables
au 21ème siècle alors fait plainte au
civil à washington at elle vraiment de
quoi enquêter
le prince héritier mohammed bin salman
écouter comme le disait le confier
donald trump à john bolton
en tout cas c'est ce que rapporte john
bolton dans son livre sur sur ses
collaborations avec le gouvernement
américain
30 se vanter d'avoir sauvé les fesses de
ben salman dans cette affaire il ya
beaucoup trop d'intérêts géopolitiques
économiques
à mon avis clients l'arabie saudite avec
les américains pour qu'un tribunal
américain puisse en toute indépendance
statut là dessus mais on est tourné
jamais à l'abri d'une bonne surprise ou
d'un revirement géopolitique slobodan
despot merci d'avoir été en direct avec
on sur rt france rappelle que vous êtes
éditeur et rédacteur en chef d'anti
presse ponette merci